so we get up next to the hive and simon
gets out his crowbar and he cranks the
lid off and seventy thousand of the most
enraged
african bees rise up in a black cloud
around
[Music]
people ask me a lot like what's the most
dangerous encounter you've had in nature
and
you know by this stage of the podcast
you know a crocodile tried to ingest me
and that wasn't the worst
but i became fascinated by bees
for a few reasons the one is that one
day i was walking
in the wild part of zimbabwe
and i came across this ancient baobab
tree it was two-story high baobab tree
and it had been hollowed out by an
elephant had knocked the branch and it
was in fact empty and a swarm of bees
had made their hive in the top of it and
the sound of the bees humming was coming
down the base of that tree and it was
like standing next to this giant
didgeridoo
and just the sort of i could hear the
intensity of the bees through this
process and i felt their vibration
coming out of this tree and it was it
kind of sparked my interest
there's also an amazing thing
in southern africa there's a bird called
the honey guide
and literally if you go out in parts of
wilderness in africa and you start
banging on trees
a bird will come to you and it will
start to call incredibly animatedly very
much like disney's i think he wants us
to follow him and then it will fly in
front of you and show you where the
beehive is so that like for thousands of
years before as a hunter-gatherer you
can rob the beehive and then you put
some honey down next to you and the bird
comes and lands next to you and eats the
honey it's this incredible ancient
just you know an encounter like that
like it just takes you back thousands of
years in an instant wow so wait just
just for clarity so this is so this is
like
thousands tens of thousands who knows
hundreds of thousands of years of
co-evolution where this bird has a
species memory
of
a symbiotic relationship with humanoids
is that what i'm hearing a type of
morphogenic field memory that's nuts
when it sees a person it knows we go and
get honey together wow isn't that
amazing that's cool and you walk out to
remote places and suddenly the birds
then it's like come on let's do this are
we going to do this and it almost
appears to get disappointed if you're
like i'm not going to go and rob the
beehive now wow so anyway like i was
around with this idea and i was like the
bees are really fascinating and then i
started reading up on them and it's this
incredible creature right they pollinate
millions of flowers they're one of the
biggest contributors
from the insect world to the economy
honey sales they can feel
electromagnetic fields they will
disappear if a storm is brewing and then
as you watch the hive itself this
incredible kind of
algorithmic intelligence whereby a
single bee
an individual bee responds to localized
stimuli doing what it knows to do
and when enough bees
responding to individual localized
stimuli
all start to attune an algorithm fires
through the hive and they move as one
and they know where to go and get food
etc so that idea also gripped me the
idea of individuals attuning to what
they know to do can trigger a kind of a
collective transformation
so i got really into this that's all the
good stuff it was a bit of back story
here before my near-death experience so
wait i should tell you that during the
time that i got fascinated about bees
there was a couple who were coming on
safari and they had been writing to me
from singapore and they were saying
listen we want to come to africa but
we're terrified of ebola and i had said
to them listen ebola is in you know
north and west africa there's no bowler
in south africa yeah but we're very very
afraid of it we're very concerned that
it could travel i said
you really have to trust me there is no
ebola in south africa you're going to be
absolutely safe so they had come on
safari meantime i walk up into the back
of the village
and i seek out a man by the name of
simon [ __ ]
simon [ __ ] great name himself has a
mellifluous voice very soft lilting
voice and simon [ __ ] is the village
beekeeper
so i say to him
simon i've got really interested in bees
and i know that you have some hives and
i would love to come and experience your
beekeeping
he says okay
there's no problem i can take your
beekeeping great i'm excited about this
he says you'll meet me tomorrow in the
morning and we will go and meet the bees
next morning i meet him
and he's got a big sort of black plastic
case
and we drive out to the hives and i'm
inappropriately dressed i'm in like
shorts and t-shirt
and i said him what do we do now he says
okay
the first thing is you must put on your
beekeeping suit
so he gives me his suit and i i put it
on and it's a little bit short for me
like literally between my sneaker and my
ankle i have some exposure
so i said him simon the suit's a bit
short for me because he had sort of this
was his second suit he says
don't worry
you can borrow my socks
so he takes his boots off and he's got
thick black socks and so i sort of feel
them and i think okay this is going to
be good and i put the socks on and i
like seal up the suit
and i say to him cool simon let's get
the smoker going now he says oh no i
don't use the smoker
it makes the bees afraid of a fire
so like a little bell goes off in my
head i'm like but beekeepers all over
the world use the smoker he says it's
not my style
i'm like oh yeah i'm here to learn
and so simon and i start heading towards
the hives and i'm talking african bees
here now term amazing thing happens
as you approach the hive
if you just walk past the hive with no
intention of doing anything
the bees somehow know it but the minute
you put your intention and attention on
them
i don't know how
you know it's maybe too woo but i'm
telling you they feel it and as you
start walking towards the hive
they start changing gears like they're
at the austin f1 track
you hear the sound changing so we get up
next to the hive and simon gets out his
crowbar and he cranks the lid off and 70
000 of the most enraged
african bees rise up in a black cloud
around me
and they're shimmering around me and you
can feel the intensity and you can feel
their attitude of oh you think you can
[ __ ] with us
and they're all around you and they
start to land on you and i you know
someone who's grown up around animals i
feel the energy of a single angry
aggressive animal
and they're all over me and i say simon
this is quite intense he says don't
worry everything's okay
and they start landing on the visor and
like blocking the visor out and it's
super intense and right at that moment
in the midst of this like
raw buzzing intensity
[Music]
one bee
found
my weak sock area
and it stung me through the sock
and the minute as that sting went
through the sock
a huge pheromonal cascade was released
to the other bees and the shimmering
swarming dark mass around my head
[Applause]
it stopped for a second
and then as one the bees went into my
ankles
and they begin to sting me intensely
through the socks the socks do not work
i think simon simon they're stinging me
simon simon they're seeing me what does
i do what does it do he says okay
back away
and they start following me and then i'm
being sung hundreds of times and then at
one stage i look up and there's a bee
that has
that's inside the suit so eventually i
get into the clearing i now have a swarm
of bees around me they are still
penetrating the sock belly simon what
must i do what does he do he says uh
hold on i will help you and he runs over
and he cuts a large branch of a tree and
then he runs back and he starts beating
me with the branch so now i'm standing
in the clearing getting pounded with the
branch and they're still singing me
they're still all around me
i say simon it's not working it's not
working he says okay i will get the
smoker going
and i just thought ran to my head like
little late for that
he grabbed the smoke he starts putting
elephant dung in it and then he gets it
going and he comes over to me and he
starts blasting me with the smoker and
the first blast went right through the
visor of the beekeeping kind of into my
mouth and so i got a big inhale of
elephant dung and then my mind and my
chest immediately tightened up i started
thinking [ __ ]
my whole body is going into anaphylaxis
is it elephant dung or is it anaphylaxis
and they're still stinging me and it's
bad i said i'm simon they're still
seeing me they're still seeing me says
oh okay
run for your life
and this is when two men in beekeeping
suits break into a full run through the
wilderness and we just start running
aimlessly at first and then he says they
will chase you forever make for the land
rover
so we run to the land rover and we jump
into it and he just says drive drive
drive they are enraged
i'll start driving off into the
wilderness
nuts we come around the first corner
and on the other safari truck driving
towards us is the couple from singapore
who've been afraid of ebola and they see
what they see is the ebola cleanup crew
in full white suits
driving towards them at full street
going you're gonna die you're gonna die
drive drive drive
and that was my first encounter with the
bee so eventually i make it back to the
house
and i remember i got into my my bedroom
and i sat on the bed and i was just
trying to feel my own body and i was
like
am i dying
am i am i dying am i okay like is it
kicking in
and i got into the shower and i took all
the stings out of my ankles and i made
it
back onto my bed and that was me for the
next five days i did not move
my my feet looked like someone had taken
um surgical gloves and just blown them
up
and simon would come around and he would
say
uh hey boyd how are you doing today said
not good he said i bought some ice for
your feet next time we will get you
boots you know i sat with it and what
what i took out of it was number one
if you wanna
the what the bees taught me is if you
wanna know about the bees respect the
bees
and
the next thing that i got was i became
intrigued by the power of
this collective ability to fire the con
like the collective consciousness
algorithm like
what would it mean if we all started
really attending to states of peace and
healing and well-being and if enough of
us did that
could we like the bees you know create
some kind of algorithmic transformation
for everyone
so i got a lot out of it
you